god bless Alabama folks it governor kiv
as I'm sure you heard who is a woman by
the way but now I suppose an honorary
member of the patriarchy signed a
near-complete abortion ban into law in
Alabama yesterday this is it's a great
victory for the pro-life movement it's a
great day for America for Liberty life
loving Americans this is a great day but
not everyone is happy of course
obviously a abortion enthusiasts are not
enthused
they are extremely upset to put it
mildly but and what we'll get to them a
minute but leaving them aside for just
just a moment even some so-called pro
lifers are concerned they have concerns
about this bill they're very concerned
Pat even Pat Robertson came out and said
that it's too extreme it's an extreme
bill and other conservatives have echoed
this saying well I'm pro-life but but
and then proceeding to explain why this
victory for the pro-life cause is not
really a victory at all and you know
it's it's it's not the right strategy
and bla bla bla listen I had you're
entitled to your own opinion I have
little patience patience for it because
we're finally making real strides we're
finally achieving big wins in multiple
states and still conservatives are not
happy they're worried that we're going
too far too fast etc etc you know what
60 million babies have been killed okay
abortion has been legal for 46 years and
60 million babies have been killed in
the mean time and you're worried we're
going too fast we're going too far 46
years of slaughter isn't enough 46 years
of gradual victories isn't gradual
enough it's not enough incrementalism
for you wait we so should we wait
another 20 years I know not at Alabama
now's not the right time let's wait
until 2040 how about that it's good
let's get another 40 50 years under our
belt stop it this is we are having this
fight right now whether you like it or
not it's happening we've done the
incremental thing for long enough and
now we're going for the throat we are
going for the abortion industry's throat
that's what we're doing and if you
consider your
self conservative get on board or go
hide on your bed but whatever you want
to do it's up to you if it makes your
tummy hurt I'm excited my tummy hurt a
little bit I'm a little uncomfortable
hey guys I'm a little uncomfortable with
this will go be uncomfortable in your
home make yourself a nice little a cup
of tea and you can sit on your couch and
the rest of us will have this fight just
don't stand in the way is the point
because the rest of us have finally
gotten to a point I think there are a
lot of people finally gone to the point
where we where we just we can't we can't
take anymore of the slaughter and the
bloodshed we can't we can't tolerate it
anymore we're not going to and so yes
extreme yeah sure sure pat robertson
we're extreme it's it's extreme we are
extremely pro-life we are extremely
against killing babies any baby for any
reason in any context that's what we're
saying and that is a a coherent logical
and morally correct point of view and so
it's it's happening
I really believe as I've been saying
that this threshold has been crossed and
we're not going back across it now
related to this topic
yours truly has been trending on Twitter
and that's that's never a good thing at
least for me you know I've never trended
on Twitter for because everyone agrees
with something I said and they're
talking about how much they like me
that's never happened for me never goes
that way the angry mob has been coming
after me because of an entirely valid
and true point that I made about
abortion and when I say angry I mean
very angry my inbox is I have just tens
of thousands of people have been
expressing their disgust with me and
I've got hundreds of messages just to
give you an idea here a couple message
I'll just read a few that I've gotten
because of my position on abortion
someone someone emailed and said I hope
your wife and daughter are both brutally
raped someone else says you are and you
are an effing [ __ ] I wish your mom
aborted you a lot of
kind of thing I wish you were aborted
kill yourself jump off a bridge
kill yourself a lot of a lot of kill
yourselves somebody met someone message
and said you're the best reason for
abortion I've ever encountered it is a
crime that your mother failed to
exercise her right and you now breathe
the free air one could only hope that by
some happening that error and judgment
is remedied this is not a threat but a
hope a wish that you and all who think
as you do are permanently silenced and
that was that was a message from Tom
mccurdy senior at Tom t om MCC u rdy SR
that he's so he's wishing that
pro-lifers are permanently silenced he's
wishing death on us he wants us dead me
specifically but if you're a pro-life
than you - also another another messages
from at PAE why ghost at Pui ghost says
absolute effing idiot you are don't
reproduce abort all three of your
already born children so wishing death
on my children and by the way you know I
put these I put these messages out there
I publish these messages on my Twitter
and I made sure to include the person's
face and name and Twitter handle and as
I'm sharing it here now because here's
the thing if you're gonna wish death on
me or my family then you don't get to do
it privately
I'm not going to respect your privacy
I'm gonna publish that for everyone to
see so if that's if that's the kind of
that's no you don't get to do that you
don't get to whisper that one to me I
mean I'm gonna pull the megaphone out
and you could say to everybody you know
it's like it's like remember in school
if you you know if you brought a snack
in the schools that well you can't you
can't eat this thing get it you'd have
to have enough for the whole share with
the whole class so it's kind of like
that if you want to wish death on
children or on your opponents then you
got to share with the whole class you
don't get to just keep that too it's not
going to stay between us
it's not it's that's not a message being
passed between us no that's not how it's
gonna work so a lot of stuff like that
and why well because I pointed out that
rapists use abortion to cover their
tracks and that abortion restrictions
can actually protect rape victims where
as abortion clinics often exploit rape
victims and can cause rape to continue
now I made that point in an exchange
that began with someone responding to
Michael Knowles after Knowles pointed
out that cases of rape and incest
account for you know less than 1% of all
abortions and someone responded to that
and said Michael Knowles is playing down
the horrible fact of the Alabama
abortion ban that if a twelve-year-old
girl gets raped by her dad and she has
to carry the baby and that the rapist
will spend less time in prison than a
doctor who aborts the baby this is
immoral
now I respond to that and said if a
twelve-year-old is raped by her father
and the father takes her to get an
abortion the evidence of the crime will
be destroyed and he will go on molesting
his victim for years if however the
child is born his crime will be
discovered and she'll be rescued from
the abuse and then I could tell you and
this exact kind of scenario happens all
the time with the help of the fine folks
at Planned Parenthood who are more than
happy to assist an abuser in covering up
the abuse and then I provided a link
with examples of precisely this sort of
thing now do I apologize for making this
point no no I do not not even a little
bit I'm not ever going to apologize for
saying something that's true is never
ever going to happen ever period now
here is a here's a story from al.com
Alabama comments assad right out of
alabama it says a Planned Parenthood
Center in Mobile provided two abortions
for a 14 year old mother of two in a
span of four months in 2014 and failed
to report that she was possibly the
victim of sexual abuse according to a
report from the Alabama Department of
Health the report states the clinic is
required by law to report possible abuse
and neglect but failed to do so after
providing services to the teenager
identified as mr16 so this you you've
got just one example 14 year old girl
coming in twice in the span of a couple
of months pregnant and the clinic does
not report it there are many examples
this kind of thing live-action had a
whole expose on this and I encourage you
to google it and find their report they
did a report about Planned Parenthood
covering up sexual abuse let me read a
few of the examples that they provide in
their report ok so reading from their
report this is what they say Denise
Fairbanks had been sexually abused by
her father abused by her father since
she was 13
when she became pregnant at age 16
he forced her to have an abortion at
Planned Parenthood although she told the
staff that he was raping her they
refused to report the incident instead
they sent her home with him where he
continued to abuse her for another year
and a half so that is pretty much
exactly the kind of scenario that I
mentioned the abortion happens it's not
reported the child is sent home and the
abuse continues now I was told that I'm
a monster for say but this this is this
that exact thing happened and this is
not the only example George Savannah had
repeatedly raped his daughter and
impregnated her when she was 14 16 and
17 years old each time taking her to
Planned Parenthood and forcing her to
get an abortion Planned Parenthood
neglected to report any of the three
suspicious incidents to authorities so
you've got fathers bringing their 13 14
15 year old daughters in for abortions
no questions asked no report nothing
police aren't called Timothy David Smith
had sexually abused his stepdaughter for
seven years and took her to Planned
Parenthood when she became pregnant at
13 planned paradin performed an abortion
without notifying her parents and
without reporting the suspected abuse to
authorities as required by law
Planned Parenthood an abortion on a
twelve-year-old at the request of eight
of her 23 year old foster brother who
was also her abuser Sean Michael Stevens
took her home afterwards and continued
to rape her planned paradin OTT only
been neglected to notify authorities but
also failed to notify the victim's
foster parents that they were going to
perform the abortion okay so this does
happen now keep in mind all those people
wishing death on me and my children is
simply because I pointed out that this
kind of thing happens the minions of the
abortion industry radical pro-abortion
zealots are truly some of the most
vicious people on earth and I this is
not my first run-in with them by a long
shot if you if you go after their sacred
cow if you desecrate the altar that they
worship upon the abortion altar they
will come after
you in just no-holds-barred and they
will feel perfectly justified in doing
it so the people that are messaging me
and saying I hope that your
five-year-old daughter is raped the
thing that's really crazy about that is
the person who sent that message feels
justified actually thinks that he or she
is justified in doing that and that was
sent anonymously it's only reason I
didn't share the name of the person who
sent me that I would love to share the
name if I had it now as for the issue of
rape and abortion more broadly as you've
heard of course the the Alabama law does
not provide for rape exceptions and this
fact has been a topic of very loud
discussion and much outrage I addressed
it briefly yesterday but now I want to
spend a little bit more time on it now
and kind of try to explain why I think
that it's it's right to not have the
rape exceptions I think mainly there are
two points to be made here okay one as
as Michael Knowles alluded to abortion
due to rape is very very rare the vast
majority of abortions have nothing to do
with rape the Guttmacher Institute
surveyed pro-abortion women and they
found that the top six reasons for
getting an abortion accounting for 85
percent of all cases were and I'll read
them to you not ready for a child can't
afford a baby have completed my
childbearing don't want to be a single
mother don't feel mature enough and
would interfere with education or career
plans okay those are the top six reasons
for getting an abortion 85 percent of
all cases and those are abortions for
lifestyle reasons they are getting rid
of the baby because the baby would
interfere with the kind of life they
want to live less than 1% of all
respondents said that they were rape
victims considering how often rape comes
up in the abortion discussion you would
think that something like half of all
women who walk into a Planned Parenthood
on a given day or rape victims but that
is clearly not the case instead of half
it's more like half of 1% so why do we
focus dis
fortunately on these rare and difficult
cases because pro-abortion people would
much rather talk about a
fifteen-year-old girl gets an abortion
because she was raped by her father then
a grown woman who gets an abortion
because she doesn't want the the you
know the baby to interfere with her
career they would much rather talk about
the former than the latter because the
latter is is is makes abortion seem
cruel and self-centered and just totally
destructive and murderous and that's
what abortion is and abortion for that
reason is many times more common than an
abortion for rape so in other words they
don't want to talk about the vast
majority you know the eighty-five to
ninety percent where it's just pretty
much clear-cut self-centered I'm killing
the baby because I don't feel like I
just don't feel like I don't feel like
having a baby they don't want to talk
about that big chunk of cases because
it's just really difficult to try to
defend that and yet still you know
appear to be taking a morally acceptable
position because if you're gonna defend
that a woman that's killing a baby just
because yeah I stuff like having a baby
if you're gonna defend that you just you
you really you have to basically abandon
morality completely and say yeah you
know I don't care about fine it's
immoral I don't care there's really just
no way to try to dress that up in moral
language it's just not possible to do so
that's why they want to focus on the on
the rare and difficult cases so that's
the first thing second thing now that
we've established that pro-abortion
people focus on hard cases in order to
distract from their real position and
that abortion restrictions will actually
protect rape victims and help assist in
bringing rapists to justice once we
qualified those the discussion with
those two crucial points I think that we
can then move on to addressing the
question at hand which is should there
be exceptions to allow
raped women to get abortions the answer
is no the pro-life case is simple okay
we believe that abortion should be
outlawed because unborn humans are
people and all people are endowed with
inherent rights and dignities there is
no other reason to be pro-life and if
we're wrong on either point if we're
wrong about you know unborn humans but
if we're wrong that unborn humans are
people or if we're wrong that all people
are endowed with human rights if we're
wrong about either of those points then
there's no reason to be pro-life at all
there's just no reason but if that's the
case then we don't need to get into rape
and incest exceptions right abortion
should simply be legal across the board
if personhood lies on a spectrum
contingent on a human beings ability to
care for himself then forget about
limiting abortion just to rape cases
actually we we shouldn't even limit it
to the womb so if we pro-lifers are
wrong about our fundamental point then
yeah of course
raped women should be able to get
abortions but also any woman should be
able to get an abortion for any reason
and probably even after birth she should
be allowed to get abortions now on the
other hand if we're right if it's true
that unborn humans are people and the
sin intrinsically deserving of the same
legal protections that you and I enjoy
then again there is no reason to discuss
exceptions a baby conceived in rape is
not any less of a person than one
conceived consensually okay if we
believe that unborn people are people
and people have rights it would be
incoherent and contradictory for us to
say well except for there are no except
fors that's the point that's our whole
point people are people are people to
pretend that a baby conceived in rape is
not a person would be nonsensical to
admit that he is a person but still
execute him for his father's sins is
morally abominable and unjustifiable we
cannot remain consistently pro-life
while supporting exceptions because the
exceptions must either be based on the
belief that not all unborn people are
people or that sometimes it is at
okay to kill a defenseless and innocent
human being but either claim would
contradict and ultimately destroy our
entire case so I say that one more time
if we support exceptions then we must
either be saying that actually as it
turns out not all unborn people are
people which would destroy the pro-life
case or we need to be saying that
actually sometimes it is okay to murder
an innocent and defenseless human being
which again destroys our entire case
because if that's if that's the case
then if we're saying that well okay you
know I mean sometimes you could kill an
innocent and defenseless human being
then okay you're making an exception for
rape but then why not I mean what what
about a woman who's just she hasn't been
raped but she's poor and you know that
having the baby would be very difficult
for her and what about all these other
difficult cases if you're saying that
sometimes it is okay to kill an innocent
defenseless human being then that went
why didn't why wouldn't that apply to
these other cases - it just seems
arbitrary it seems like we either take a
hard-line stance that it is never okay
to kill an innocent and defenseless
human being ever under any circumstance
we take that position or we say that
math sometimes it is okay and if we take
the approach then I think we've opened
the floodgates - oh then suddenly
everything becomes an exception because
if
if it can be okay to kill to
intentionally kill an innocent
defenseless human being then I guess
what we're saying is that human life is
not actually quite as valuable as we had
been insisting all this time okay so
that's that's that's where it comes down
to and that doesn't mean listen a couple
other points here obviously when we're
talking about these extreme rare hard
cases obviously I have nothing but
compassion and sympathy for a woman who
is in that position it's unimaginable I
mean it really is unimaginable and I as
I said yesterday I think if you want to
talk about aborting rapists if you want
to talk about abortion for the scumbag
who raped her then we could definitely
have that discussion I think there's a
case to be made for that for sure for
executing rapists we could definitely
talk about that because of what a just
horrific unthinkable barbaric crime it
is to do that to someone huge it you you
have to be an animal you have basically
by your own decision you have forfeited
your humanity and and that's why I say
you know it's never okay to
intentionally kill an innocent and
defenseless human being but that doesn't
mean that it's that it's that it's
necessarily wrong to kill a guilty and
and a dangerous human being so you know
that's if we want to if someone is going
to be punished for a rape then I think
obviously we punish the rapist and
punish him severely but I just I don't
see how you
punish the child with death especially
and I don't see how that is going to
help the woman heal either you know
adding more death and suffering and
misery in the long term I don't see how
that helps anyone I don't see how it
ever can so that's you know so
that'sthat's the the important point
also oh we seem to struggle with this
with a nuance here where you know you
have the objective quality of an act so
we say so I say abortion is objectively
evil and it is it is objectively
inherently evil act and it is never okay
it is always evil to do however the the
moral culpability of an individual who
engages in an evil act can vary it can
vary tremendously significantly so I
would say that in these extreme cases
there's a fifteen-year-old girls raped
and and gets an abortion people said
well you're heartless you that you would
call that evil well it is an evil act
yes but it would also seem to me that
the moral guilt of the girl in a
position is severely mitigated now I
can't I can't sit here and say how how
mitigated precisely it is that's not for
me to say it's for God to say but it
does seem to me that it is severely
mitigated given the situation that she's
in and that this is a was someone who's
been abused is afraid is I mean just is
you can't even Majan the the mindset of
someone like that so I can acknowledge
all that I understand those nuances and
I acknowledge how when we talk about
hard cases I acknowledge just how hard
they really are and I also acknowledge
that because I've never been in that
position I can't I can't I can't I can't
fully appreciate how hard they really
are I acknowledge all of that but
doesn't change the fact that a person is
a person there is a person is another
person involved in that person is a
person and it doesn't matter how hard
the case is it will not detract from the
personhood of this third person who is
now involved all right um
let's move on before we get the emails I
wrote something yesterday with kind of a
click Beatty title admittedly but I do
feel that I back it up so it's not
really clickbait but the title is the
simple preschool level question that no
leftist can answer and and here's the
here's the point I was trying to make
and I made this point before but I I'm
just gonna lay it out now because I have
been there's a certain question that I
have been desperately asking with
increasing desperation I've been asking
this question of leftist people on the
left trying to get someone to answer it
and so now I put it out here in this
forum as well if there's anyone on the
left watching right now I've got a
question for you and I rely would just
love to hear your answered I mean that
sincerely it's a very simple question
like I said preschool level I just want
to know what your answer is now you'll
notice of course that folks on the Left
use the word woman quite a bit we all
use the word woman or it's a common word
to use but especially leftist they make
claims about women they say that these
people known as women have something
called women's rights they say that
those rights are under attack they say
that women are persecuted and
disadvantaged by something called male
privilege they say that women are the
victims of something called a wage gap
they say things like we need a woman
president right they say all that kind
of stuff they also say that biological
males can be women they say trans women
are women they say that someone can
start out life as a male and then
transition into a woman so they make
many other claims in that vein but how
can I understand any of those
claims if I do not know what they mean
when they say the word woman and how can
how can they make any meaningful
statements about women if they
themselves don't know what they mean by
it so the question I ask is this what is
a woman simple question what is a woman
define the word now in fairness I'll
provide my own definition I tend to
agree with merriam-webster that woman
means an adult female person that's the
dictionary definition that is also the
definition that the whole history of
human civilization had it would have
would have would have given up until
very recently but you on the left you
disagree you say that biology has
nothing to do with womanhood well then
what does have something to do with
womanhood if we cannot define a woman
physically how can we define her what is
a woman you know your definition must be
specific if you make all of these
specific statements about what it's like
to be a woman the trials and
tribulations that women face the
indignities that women suffer and so on
yeah we were told that Captain Marvel
was an important movie because it had a
was a woman lead superhero film okay
well so that means what that brie Larson
is a woman okay well now we're getting
somewhere brie Larson is a woman I agree
with you there brie Larson is also an
adult female with all of the biological
markers of a female so the picture seems
to be coming into focus maybe Webster
had it right after all the wait a second
you also say that Caitlyn Jenner and
Chelsea Manning are women despite the
fact that they are both adult males not
females you say that they're all three
equally woman brie Larson Caitlyn Jenner
tells many you say they're all good so
they're distinguishable they're women
woman woman woman well suddenly the
picture becomes foggy again I've been
told by the few people that have
attempted to answer this question and
there have been a few I've been putting
this question out everywhere
and and a few people have tried to
answer it on the left and the answer
that I've gotten is that a woman is
anyone who identifies as a woman but
that definition doesn't work because you
can't use the word you're defining in
the definition if I asked you for the
definition of tree and you tell me that
a tree is that which you know a tree is
that which is a tree well you've told me
nothing about trees I need you to
explain trees using words that don't
include the word tree you can't use the
word of the depth so what's the
definition of desc
well desk is desk does it work
I need you to explain the word without
using the word I need you to explain
woman using words that don't include
woman give me a definition of woman that
does not have the word woman in it
that's what a definition is so what is a
woman you might say that a woman is an
adult human female or anyone who
identifies as an adult human female but
that's just another way of saying that a
woman is an adult human female or not an
adult human female and that's just
another way of saying that that a woman
is nothing in particular woman has no
definition if that is the definition
then woman has no definition and it
would be nonsensical to identify as a
woman in that case because you're
identifying as something that is not
really anything when a man says I
identify as a woman okay what what is
that thing that your idea what do you
mean by that
is the question what do you mean by that
what is it that you're identifying as
that is a fair question if you can't
answer it then that's a problem now I'll
be told that words like woman and man
are on a spectrum
okay well then tell me about this
spectrum I have fine it's on a spectrum
it's not on a spectrum but I'll go along
with it for a moment for the sake of
argument spectrum right so spectrum
point a point B and then you've got the
the you know the gradual increments
between okay what are these things on
either side of the spectrum define the
people who exist on either side defying
the people who exist on what I would
call the woman's side of the spectrum if
someone is on the spectrum so if someone
is like right here on the spectrum
between woman and man okay well what
does that mean they're between what and
what you can't escape the definition
problem by talking about spectrums if
the spectrum takes us from one
undefinable thing to another undefinable
thing that it's not a spectrum it's more
like a black hole we're all sense and
reason and the very laws of science
break down so what exactly does any of
this mean what is a woman is a woman in
the end just anyone who enjoys feminine
things or dresses in a feminine way well
that can't be it because we can't define
feminine until we've defined the word
woman the definition of feminine hinges
very much on the definition of woman and
also this definition would turn a lot of
women into non women and a lot of non
women into women besides the left has
been trying to break down the societal
construct of feminine vers masculine for
years surely you can't go from not all
women should be expected to be feminine
to the only defining characteristic of
women is that they are feminine I mean
you can't do such a 180 and undermine
everything you've been saying for the
last 60 years so what is a woman it does
not seem possible to formulate a
definition of woman that rejects biology
while still allowing women to be
objective unique and and discernible
things while still allowing womanhood to
be a discernible category but I invite
anyone to prove me wrong I invite any
leftist to prove me wrong
what is a woman that's the question and
you can
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com you know if
you're if you're a rational person and
you know that a woman is an adult human
female then I don't need your answer I
know you're into it but if you're on the
left and you're as you subscribe to the
leftist gender theory give me a
definition if you I will and if you can
give me one that makes sense
I'll read it on the show and and I will
admit that I have been defeated I really
don't think that's gonna happen I don't
think you can define the word I think I
think it is a word you use all the time
but that you cannot define according to
your political according to the the
dictates of your ideology you can't
define it alright let's see okay Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com we'll go to
emails from Lisa says greetings Matt
I've seen some pro Boortz online trying
to prove hypocrisy and pro-lifers by
claiming that we don't care about frozen
embryos that are destroyed so we aren't
really pro-life from conception I
actually can't recall ever hearing about
frozen embryos in the pro-life
conversation at all what's your take on
it morally and legally is it even moral
to have embryos artificially created and
frozen much less discarded well that is
something that comes up in discussion I
think frequently and a lot of pro lifers
are spoken out about this are outspoken
about it I should say and the answer is
no I don't think that it is ethical to
create these embryos like they are just
resources and keep them in a storage
locker somewhere keep them in a freezer
somewhere I think it is the the in a
real literal sense it's the
objectification or maybe I should say
the commodification of human life
returning human life into a commodity
and saying oh you know I got I got I got
50 embryos and storage and you know if I
get around to using what I got back I
got spares here I got backups I think
it's a it's a very dangerous thing it is
not respecting of the dignity of the
human person and so that's where I stand
on
now a variation of this is you lie I
thought that's where you were gonna go
with this where somebody will say okay
well you're you're in a you know you're
in a fertility clinic and and there's a
fire and you could only say and there's
there's a you know ten frozen embryos in
a box or a thousand frozen embryos in a
box and there's a two-year-old child you
can only save one in the fire now why is
the two-year-old child in the freezer
with the embryos I have no idea but
that's the hypothetical you can only
save one which one do you save and maybe
I don't know if you've heard this this
brain teaser before I've addressed it
before I think one of the first pieces I
ever wrote for The Daily wire was
actually addressing this question and
just very briefly the answer of course
is that you would save the two-year-old
child right I mean anybody would that is
I guess supposed to prove that we don't
really consider embryos to be human life
but of course it proves no such thing I
would save a two-year-old over a 72 year
old I would probably save a two-year-old
over a you know 30 year old I would save
a two-year-old over someone who's you
know probably over someone who's
terminally ill I would say I would save
the two-year-old over a lot of people
and does that mean that I don't think
the other people are people if I if I
save the two-year-old over someone who's
72 does that mean that I don't think
that I think seventy two year olds
aren't human beings or they aren't
people or their life their lives aren't
aren't worthwhile or or that they are
somehow worth less than the the
two-year-old no doesn't mean that at all
it just means that in that extremely
difficult and of course also far-fetched
and ridiculous scenario you have to make
a quick decision and that decision is
not going to be based on which of these
are human it's gonna be based on other
things first of all that's gonna be
there's gonna be a motion to it like you
see a two-year-old it just elicits
certain emotions from you and so you're
gonna respond to those emotions and
that's that's fine and you'll maybe you
make other calculations and you and you
say in this case it looked you know
the two-year-old has on his whole life
in front of him 70 two-year-olds already
lived a long life
I mentioned someone who's terminally ill
I mean you might make the choice in that
scenario will to your all has a whole
life further this is someone who's who's
unfortunately near death already so it's
just you've got to make a decision and
so you make that decision there but
again that does not mean that you're
denying the humanity of the person you
don't save and another thing very
important is that you're not killing the
other person so if this if the
hypothetical is well you got to toss one
of them into the fire yeah they're gonna
toss the embryos into the fire or the
child into the fire well the answer to
that is neither even with a gun to your
head you you should do neither and die
rather than do that because it is never
okay to directly intentionally kill
innocent defenseless human life that's
the the point here but when you're when
you could only save one and you said you
make your choice you're not killing the
other person if that person dies
tragically it's the fire that kill you
did it to it unless you set the fire
assuming that's not the case it's not
your fault you could only save one so
it's just not it's not synonymous with
abortion abortion is not choosing
someone to save from a fire abortion is
tossing someone into the fire very
different all right this is from tom
says hi man I was trying
from Chicago today listen your podcast
when I look up to see you standing right
next to me in the pre-check line I know
that you're an introvert from being an
avid listener to your show and knowing
my introverted self I certainly would
not like someone coming up to me while I
was rushing through security line trying
to take out my laptop take off my shoes
etc I wanted to take the chance to thank
you but by the time you were through
security I had lost you
well you could have come up to me Tom I
always I always appreciate that but I am
it says I'm from Philadelphia
unfortunately I could not attend the
rally last week many of my family
members were there thank you for
organizing such an amazing day and thank
you for all that you've done for the
pro-life movement I got to listen to
your speech and rally during my lunch
break it was very moving I didn't
realize that me reading a bunch of
compliments to myself honestly but I
appreciate it Tom
my wife and I have prayed slash Minister
that planned parenthood with 40 days for
life and it made me so proud to see so
many pro lifers come together in
response to Brian Simms made me proud as
well I agree we are beginning to see a
shift in the culture and I believe that
has a lot to do with your constant
battle for life and willingness to stand
up in the face of death okay ty I don't
want to no disrespect I'm gonna skip
ahead to the I don't want to keep
reading these appreciate I'll finish
reading it off air I just feel
uncomfortable reading compliments about
me publicly
it feels very self-serving alright
here's the question maybe that was okay
my question would be what is your advice
on sharing a pro-family pro-life message
in the corporate workplace or any
mention of these issues is frowned upon
all right there was a question well yeah
I get this got a question a lot and I
think of the quote that's attributed to
st. francis of assisi which i think
maybe he didn't actually say but it's
you know preach the gospel if necessary
use words i'm sure you've heard that
before
and i think it's a very similar thing
for the situation a yeren corporate
workplace you you you can't go around
lecturing people about the pro-life
cause or you know sharing your political
opinions all the time in the workplace
you just can't do that it's not it's not
the appropriate place for it you're the
your your bosses and the p your employer
probably does not want that and and for
good reason you know because that's not
it's your at the job to do a job you're
not there to have political arguments
it's not going to be conducive to a
productive work environment when when
when there are political debates about
abortion and everything so I think in
that scenario that's a time for
preaching the message without using
words and if you're just which it sounds
like you are just a decent good person
and demonstrating that to people then
when they discover if it ever comes up
if you ever are talking to them outside
of work or if somehow it does come up
and they discover that
oh you're pro-life you're pro-family
you're a Christian once when they
discover that they're gonna they're
there all the sudden going to make this
association between oh this is a
person's against abortion I also know is
a very decent and good person and that's
gonna be a very powerful witness for
them and you didn't even need to say
anything they just see it they connect
those two things because there are a lot
of people who just who really you know
you hear from this argument from from
pro-abortion people oh you're just Pro
birth you don't care about anyone after
they're born right it's so it's so
absurd the people who say that these are
people who it seems like have never met
a pro-life person because if you've ever
actually met a pro-life person you would
realize that these are people who very
often or very cheder charitable very
compassionate very generous and so you
are providing that witness to other
people just by being a decent person and
that's how I would go about that finally
from Matt says your argument for rapists
loving abortion is not a good argument
the rapists DNA could still be collected
from an aborted baby also a baby doesn't
have to be carried to term to obtain the
babies genetic material genetic testing
such as t21 can pick up the babies
genetic material in the mothers
bloodstream in the first trimester to be
clear I'm fairly close to your position
on abortion generally I just think that
part of the argument was poorly
thought-out well I appreciate that
point of view
but as I tried to explain meant that
would require the abortion clinics to
actually report the abuse and to be
proactive and what we've discovered is
that abortion clinics very often are not
going to do that they're not interested
in getting and getting involved in that
in reporting it in fact they have a
vested financial interest in not
reporting it and their interest is
number one you know rape victims are
still paying for the abortions so they
make money off of it and number two they
don't want this association to be they
don't want people to realize that oh you
know rapists try to use abortion to
cover a break they they don't want to
call attention to that they don't want
to call attention to the fact that um
you know a rapist father brought his
victim in to get an abortion they don't
want to call attention that so they're
more likely to ignore it and number
three would keep in mind what these
people do for a living they kill human
beings for a living this is what they do
every day so obviously these are not
going to be people who you can trust to
make ethical decisions these are going
to be self-centered people who care
about the bottom line and are completely
callous towards suffering and towards
innocent human life they have to be in
order to do this for a living which is
why you just can't trust them for
anything and it's it's why it just
doesn't work it doesn't work to have you
say well you're gonna borscht your
clinics and have all these regulations
and laws and you expect them to do this
and and what you find is that abortion
clicks they ignore the regulations they
ignore the laws they were ignore the
reporting requirements they ignore the
health codes and everything else because
of because again they kill people for a
living
what do they care about a reporting
requirement rape abuse sanitizing the
equipment they don't care about that
they have had they've forfeited their
souls just to do this for a living these
are these are people who don't even have
it in them to make ethical decisions
which is why we could
never trust them to do the right thing
and to call someone and report it
doesn't mean that means sometimes maybe
someone over there does do the right
thing but we can never trust them to do
the right thing and we have to expect
that very often they will not and then
if the abort if they do the examples I
gave to do the abortion the dead child
is discarded as medical waste and that's
it it's gone and that's the evidence is
gone a lot more than evidence is gone a
human life is gone but also the evidence
of the crime is gone and they're one of
the reasons why that is so terrible is
that not only will this rapist not face
justice but then that child will be sent
home with the rapist as in the examples
I provided that's exactly what happened
all right but thank you for the email
thanks everybody for watching your
listening Godspeed the College Board
adds a new adversity score to the SAT
grievance goes mainstream we will
examine social justice and its opposite
you know actual justice check it out at
the Michael Nolt show